we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and i have
some news that how do I introduce this I
mean I guess it's news that some people
will be disappointed by and some people
will be thrilled by and the news is that
the Texas troll is quitting the David
Pakman show
resigning and unsubscribing from the
David Pakman show why I'll let him tell
you he can say it much more eloquently
than I ever could yeah David I think
it's finally time for me to unsubscribe
it's really sad because I watched her
show for a while
but after seeing your latest segment on
Rachel Maddow some caller called and
asked you about Rachel Maddow and you
really didn't pound her as hard as I
thought you were I'm starting to realize
that you're the same as everyone on
MSNBC and then I read all the comments
on my video and everyone's defending
Rachel Maddow
yeah that's pretty disgusting Rachel
Maddow is a horrible horrible horrible
person and part of corporate media and
part of what's wrong with this country
goodbye David it was fun while it lasted
it was more for you than for us listen
I've met Rachel Maddow a couple of times
and as far as a person goes I disagree
that she's a bad person she seems like a
very very nice person and was very
friendly and nice that's that's number
one number two I when the caller called
in and asked me about Rachel Maddow I I
basically said I don't watch her show
the one time I've seen her show in the
last four years is the day that she
teased Tom Trump's twenty two thousand
five a 1040 tax return and I thought it
was underwhelming and I don't watch the
show so like how can what did you expect
me to say it's a show I don't watch the
only episode I've seen in years is that
one episode and also why would you go by
YouTube comments to decide whether you
want to watch our show or not I mean our
YouTube comments are also riddled with
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
people calling me you know a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but is that a reflection of anything
that we're saying on the show seems like
a weird reason but but listen we're not
gonna hear from the Texas troll anymore
he says he sells everything out and
that's gonna be tough I think but with
all relationships you
learn from each other and George will
get through it it'll take a few weeks
maybe but and not everything lasts
forever not everything lasts forever
that's the reality things good things
end now we're taking applications for
the new Texas troll yeah have to be a
troll and have to be from Texas I
actually would rather just have the
Kansas troll start calling back in
because he's basically the best troll
we've ever had and remember when he
actually he called in during live calls
and tried to troll us and it totally
face-planted it's amazing I hope he
calls it I like the troll who only
trolls some of the time so you don't
know when he's trolling and well thanks
the area that that was the Texas troll
remember when he was the guy yeah yeah
yeah he's the guy who disclosed I only
am sometimes trolling anyway
goodbye Texas troll some people will
miss you
I would guess on the bonus show today we
will talk about the school officer an
interesting role the school officer I
have actually stories about the school
officer at my high school we will talk
about Stephen Hawking who says he thinks
he might know what happened before the
beginning of time and how Tesla might
contaminate Mars a very interesting
story on the bonus show which you can
get access to by signing up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership use the coupon code new code
vote soon 18 vote soon 18 saves you 40%